mine spilled out into the streets as
fans flocked to their nearest cinema to
watch the culmination of a decade of
Marvel movies when Avengers endgame
finally arrived in theaters and judging
from the reaction on Twitter
the vast majority left more than happy
warning spoilers ahead filmmaker and
self professed fanboy Kevin Smith got to
attend the end game world premiere with
his daughter Harley Quinn Smith yes the
man loves comics unsurprisingly the
Mallrats director absolutely loved the
movie and he was eager to share that
pact taking to Twitter afterwards Smith
predicted that endgame was going to
smash box-office records three hours
later and I'm shook my god Avengers end
game is beyond epic it's everything you
hope it will be and more an absolute
Marvel Studios marvel and I'm pretty
sure what will make all the money ever
printed loved it and would watch again
instantly the hype surrounding Avengers
endgame was so huge that it would have
been considered a disappointment if it
was anything short of the best superhero
movie ever made
fortunately for Marvel and everyone
involved with the picture it was exactly
that at least according to Emmy
nominated producer and film critic Scott
mance who tweeted ncredible brings the
entire MCU to a rousing exciting deeply
moving and wholly satisfying conclusion
it's a beautiful film fun smart clever
brilliant perfect blend of action parts
and humor this is as good as it gets
greatest superhero movie ever with a
runtime of three hours and one minute
Marvel ran the risk of dragging out
proceedings somewhat but if anything
three hours and one minute wasn't enough
the film hurtles by as loose ends are
tied and sacrifices are made culminating
in a battle of truly epic proportions
after the time-traveling Avengers
finally managed to bring the Infinity
stones back to the present
Thanos arrives to wipe them and the rest
of humanity out for good
one thing's for sure the final act of
the movie really sticks with you YouTube
star Noah J four-five-six tweeted I
can't stop thinking about it I think the
last hour of avengers endgame was the
greatest hour of film ever to be shown
on the big screen cinema blend events
editor Eric Eisenberg describes himself
as a film and comics obsessive in his
Twitter bio meaning he's the kind of guy
whose
particularly hard to please when it
comes to superhero movies judging from
the tweet he sent out after scene
endgame for the first time
Marvel exceeded expectations with this
picture this can't be understated
Avengers endgame is everything you want
it to be and more
I am absolutely floored a perfect
reflection of the last 11 years that
pays off everything in the best way
possible without question my new
favorite Marvel Cinematic Universe film
stunned character limits mean nothing
when you've got a good mean Twitter
users were in good form when endgame was
released but MCU fans using images and
movie clips to convey the emotions that
their words simply could not one user by
the name of RI Peter Parker posted a
screenshot of chadwick boseman King
T'Challa visiting his father in the
ancestral plane and confessing that he's
not ready to move on without him with
the image they wrote be staying in my
seat and refusing to leave the cinema
after the credits roll because I'm far
too attached to these characters and the
story you have had you others have been
poking fun at the fact that Marvel has
urged people not to spoil the movie
hosting what they're calling spoilers
without context
these range from beer bellies and rats
to cheeseburgers and tacos if you've
seen endgame by now you get it the word
epic is probably thrown around a little
too liberally in the world of pop
culture and the word was used a lot on
Twitter following the premiere of
endgame was this just fans doing what
fans do and going overly crazy over
something they love or is end game truly
epic
according to novelist and veteran
reporter Anthony president can it most
certainly is in his estimation epic is
the word epic multiplied by a decade of
emotion excitement and investment this
is the payoff it left me with a full
heart but one I had has some scars on it
those are the strongest kind after all
while many have been trolling Avengers
fans with wild and elaborate fake
spoilers some people have broken the
Golden Rule and revealed big details
from the movie on Twitter we're going to
dive into those big spoilers right now
so this is your last chance to keep
endgame a secret if you haven't seen it
matter of fact you may do well to stay
off the internet entirely because
charmingly blunt tweets like this one
are definitely making the rounds
Iron Man die
natasha romanoff dies Captain America
gets old technically implied dead Thoris
fats Gamora is now alive and Loki is
also alive Valkyrie is now the ruler of
Asgard
Thanos disappears Tony Stark has a
daughter Bruce Banner and Hulk live as
one so it's smart Hulk and yeah that
pretty much sums the whole thing up it
happened with Josh Brolin Stannis after
infinity war but this time out Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk was Twitter's bizarre
crush Ruffalo has played Bruce Banner in
the hole for years now so what's the big
deal
this time they're one and the same and
the result is giving some Twitter users
confusing feelings as one smitten fan
tweeted hey not to be predictably me but
why is Professor Hulk so hot another
said that they were sticking to their
guns despite the critics declaring I'm
being bullied for speaking my truth
yes I'd smash Hulk he's the hot
professor I've always wanted check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]